[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport sur tv 78 c'est parti pour le
sommaire volley ball les féminines du
club de vélizy se sont imposés ce
week-end dans l'heure pour leur premier
match de la saison en nationale 3 contre
le paris volley le score est sans appel
3-0 coup de projecteur dans ce magazine
équitation le club du sky équitation
organisé ce week-end une compétition
trois étoiles avec plus de 400 cavaliers
dont des champions olympiques
reportage à suivre tennis en plein
roland garros coup de projecteur sur les
talents évinois présents sur ce rendez
vous porte d'auteuil comme arthur et
daphné ch
chloé paquet ou encore antoine ghibaudo
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres nous
allons parler des jo de 2024 la
fédération française de cyclisme l'a
confirmé la colline d'elancourt est bien
accueillir les épreuves de vtt lors des
jeux parisiens un temps remis en
question le site a été confirmée dans le
dossier les courses de bmx ont également
été confirmés dans l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines tout comme les
épreuves d'équitation à versailles un
temps envisagée à lamotte beuvron les
yvelines vont également organiser le
cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome national
de golf golf national en écoute la
réaction de laurent mazuray vice
président délégué aux sports sur la
confirmation des sites à saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est une excellente nouvelle ville est
vrai que nous avions eu un peu peur mais
un tout petit peu peur parce qu'il nous
semblait absolument logique que nos
sites soit confirmée le seul sur lequel
planait encore un léger doute
c'était celui de la colline d'elancourt
pour les épreuves de vtt et bien c'est
chose faite cette semaine tout a été
plutôt la semaine dernière tout a été
confirmé
la logique est respectée c'était le plus
beau site le site le plus adapté le site
le plus près de paris est aussi un c'est
pas neutre est le site le plus
écologique donc c'est ce site qui est
retenu nous aurons donc bien à 50 en et
v4 cité six épreuves le département
pourrait également recevoir une partie
des épreuves de cyclisme sur route la
validation définitive de tous ses sites
devrait intervenir d'ici à la fin de
l'année avec une confirmation du cio on
va maintenant parler de volley ball en
nationale 3 féminine le club de vélizy
retrouver la compétition ce week-end
face au paris volley non rencontre
maîtrisée qui a vu les bélizienne
l'emporté 3 sets à 0 des images d'astrid
bergère
c'était l'heure de la reprise pour les
féminines de vélizy pour leur première
rencontre de nationale 3 les bélizienne
en recevait ce dimanche 4 octobre paris
volley de rencontre maîtrisée du début à
la fin par les joueuses locales encore
en rodage score est sans appel 3-0 25-18
dans la première manche 25 17 dans la
seconde et 25-21 dans la dernière très
heureuse d'avoir gagné ce premier match
de la saison
ça fait plaisir plutôt satisfait de la
prestation des joueuses
effectivement on pensait que l'équipe
adverse elle est un peu plus dure à
jouer et en fait on a réussi à hausser
notre niveau de jeu donc plutôt sa dette
très satisfait pour un premier match de
l'année après six mois sans jouer quoi
c'est très content après cette
performance le club de vélizy pointe à
la cinquième place du classement mais le
club compte un match en moins sur les
leaders
si on peut continuer à jouer ça signifie
voilà une bonne entrée en matière - une
pression par la suite parce que du coup
on engage tout de suite à avec un bon
résultat on est con on montre qu'on est
capable de faire des choses donc sa
annonce que du positif on sait que
théoriquement common a mal fini l'année
dernière on va jouer les équipes censées
plus forte sur début de saison donc
c'est pour ça qu'on est content de ce
match là parce que effectivement c'était
censé être unique plus grosses équipes
que ça maintenant voilà les épaules de
les équipes du nord
risa plus rigoureux statut prête on
verra ça sera surprise du chef
prochain match pour le club de vélizy ce
dimanche 11 octobre à 16 heures sur le
terrain de liévinois l'équipe qui a
remporté ses deux premiers matches de la
saison
en tennis arthur rédac neige a disputé
lundi dernier pour la première fois
cette année roland garros sont simples
le joueur originaire de 25 ans formé à
saint germain en laye et au comité des
yvelines de feucherolles aujourd'hui
163e joueur mondial s'est incliné au
premier tour face au slovène aljaz
bedene et 56e joueur mondial
arthur rinderknecht a quand même réussi
à lui prendre un set le score 6 2 6 7 6
4 6 4
on continue à parler de roland garros et
du tennessee vinoy arthur guinness
n'était pas le seul joueur originaire du
département présents sur la quinzaine
cou et paquet formé à versailles a aussi
été éliminé lors du premier tour face à
la française alizé cornet 6-3 6-2 à cela
il faut ajouter le jeune antoine
ghibaudo présent dans le tournoi jeunes
juniors
pour nous en parler avec mon plateau
patrick ottaway conseiller sportif
territorial et jean-françois m'étais
secrétaire général du comité des vignes
de tennis bonsoir bonsoir
alors on va revenir sur la performance
d'arthur est-ce que vous l'attendiez ce
niveau là la tour des asticots là la
seule inconnue qu'on avait c'était
premier roland garros
peut-être un peu de fébrilité table il a
fait les qualifiés
hier il a fait un excellent match par
rapport aux conditions de jeu par
rapport à un joueur qui est un peu plus
fort que lui il arrive à lui prendre un
set qui rate un petit peu le coche au
troisième il a une petite occases mais
là il n'y a pas beaucoup de place mais
n'ont très satisfaisant super
comportement super attitude
bon on est fier de lui sinon pas de
soucis et vous le suivez depuis des
années je lesieu moi je le suis depuis
ce film depuis très longtemps puisque
moi j'ai eu à l'entraînement comité de
feucherolles quand il était en quatrième
il a suivi sa scolarité avec des
horaires un lampion ou au collège
d'abord jean monnet ou ou lycées
sursaute sonia delaunay à villepreux
puis il est parti faire ses études aux
états unis il avait il a continué à
jouer au tennis et ça fait deux ans
maintenant qui s'est lancé sur le
circuit avec une très belle progression
de très très bons résultats en début
d'année puisqu'il a gagné deux
challengers en simple au canada et
malheureusement decaux vide est tombé et
la saison s'est arrêtée mais bon voilà
il a fait une très très belle
progression sur le début de l'année il
est 55e à l'arrêt je crois jean-françois
mais tu es ce que vous avez suivi son
match également oui mercury un agrégé
bien sûr on les suit on les suit faut
dire qu'arthur est aussi pourrait
compléter avec le double il a il a passé
un tour on va parler justement un double
oui la journée qu on avec manuel guinard
qui est son partenaire d'entraînement
c'est bien ça là il s'est entraîné en
rentrant des états unis a haussé est né
à roland garros et il a il a essayé de
chercher une cellule qu'il soit un petit
peu plus individualisé pour lui et donc
il est parti à rennes s'entraîner avec
emmanuel dinars qui est de la même année
que lui et ils s'entendent bien il joue
bien en double et ils ont passé leur
premier tour cette année de grand chelem
et se sert et voilà contre face aux
anglais un jamie murray et neil scoop ce
qui axe qui voit là se démarque depuis
encore aujourd'hui donc très bonne
équipe de double ils ont eu une
opportunité perdue en trois sets par un
très bon match
rien à dire une petite opportunité au
troisième ou au second il aurait
peut-être pu plier la faire en deux sets
c'est pas passé il ya un peu de
fébrilité mais c'est de l'expérience
accumulée
ils vont continuer à progresser je suis
pas inquiet justement arthur c'est plus
un joueur de double ou de simples c'est
un joueur c'est un joueur qui est
capable de s'adapter et en simple et en
double je pense qu' il va faire on joue
on lui souhaite évidemment de faire la
plus belle des carrières en simple comme
en double mais il n'y a rien qui peut
trop limité que ce soit en simple en
double avec un gros service
un coup fort le coup droit il a beaucoup
progressé à la volée aux états unis
parce que les matches par équipe aux
états unis les doubles compte énormément
et il a beaucoup progressé on double
aussi là bas
non non je pense que il faut qu'ils
crohot deux et on y croit pour lui en
tous les cas de sai a pas de problème
gens font ça m'était j'imagine que c'est
une grande fierté d'avoir un talent
comme arthur bien sûr dans les élites
tous ces jeunes là qu'on a formé depuis
depuis l'europe depuis leur enfance on
les suit et quand qui progresse et quand
ils évoluent de cette manière on peut
être que satisfait et on suit
aujourd'hui avec beaucoup d'attention le
parcours d'antoine vous allez aborder
peut-être tout à l'heure antoine bibeau
d'eau qu'on a depuis tout petit et qui
s'entraîne presque à 100% au comité
voilà des gens qui sont bondées des
jeunes qui sont bien dans leur tête
qu'ils sont et ça fait plaisir de voir à
ce niveau là antoine bibeau d'eau et on
va parler tout de suite si la perdre
il est à gagner justement aujourd'hui
face à l'indien j'avias est ce que c'est
une surprise de le voir à ce niveau là
en sachant qu'il est programmé pour
gagner il faut le dire ils tous les
joueurs sont programmés pour gagner et
tous les joueurs veulent gagner mon par
contre lui c'est son premier roland
garros
il a joué un joueur plus âgé que lui un
faux-pas faut rappeler que
antoine il a 16 ans il voilà donc très
belle performance d'antoine il joue
contre un indien qui à mon avis aurait
été plus dur à jouer sur une surface
plus rapide mais là il a vraiment saisi
les opportunités il a eu un super
comportement il passe son premier tour
pour son premier junior dans un tournoi
du grand chelem
on est super content pour lui parce que
pour la confiance c'est très très bien
comment fait justement pour protéger un
talent comme antoine bibeau dos mais je
pense que déjà il est dans une structure
qui lui convient parfaitement
c'est à dire qu'il est avec nous et
raison sa structure familiale
donc c'est par ses parents qui sont très
proches de lui donc il est très bien
entouré une équipe vos comités killeuse
un cocon et je pense que c'est la clé de
la réussite se se mélangent famille
comité entraîneur qui vraiment sont
derrière lui une chose qui est vraiment
importante
c'est c'est la famille en fait le comité
des yvelines
il vient au comité des vignes depuis
qu'il est tout petit son père s'est
entraîné au comité des yvelines moi je
les ai eus à l'entraînement vincent
c'est la famille on se sent comme à la
maison et au niveau de l'affect des
émotions etc
on arrive à générer beaucoup de
confiance on a dédié son entraîneur
julien des mois qui travaillent avec
nous ils sont nos qu à 100% donc on a
essayé d'optimiser toutes les conditions
de la réussite de la performance plus le
fait qu'ils sentent vraiment en famille
voilà la confiance est important il y
avait également une joueuse sûreté en
tennis féminin il y avait à chloé paquet
qui a été formé à versailles alors bien
saint cloud et chloé et et du club du
tgv et nous on a eu dans notre structure
en aménager au comité des yvelines aussi
toute petite et elle a été formée à 80%
au comité des yvelines et à 20% au tc
gvt et chloé qui est d'ailleurs la
cousine d'arthur tout ça c'est une
famille sort d'une famille assez
j'habiterai tennis donc voila et
là aussi bon elle a fait un premier tour
où elle est entre alizé cornet contre
alizé cornet 95e joueuse mondiale elle
et 185e alors a été mieux mais elle
était très tendue donc les passer un
petit peu à côté de son match mais bon
elle va rebondir n'y a pas de problème
alors on l'a vu il ya trois champions
trois grands champions dans les yvelines
il y en ad'autres également qui est qui
arrive est ce qu'on peut dire que le
département divine a réussi son quota ou
pas de champion oui enfin les quotas on
n'a pas trop de quotas notre objectif
c'est effectivement de est ce qu'on peut
faire mieux on peut toujours faire mieux
mais je pense que là on est pas mal club
donc mais il faut toujours se remettre
en cause et on peut toujours faire mieux
bien sûr on est très attentif et nos
conseillers en ontario sont là pour
aller dans les clubs voir un petit peu
dans les structures avec les enseignants
professionnels des clubs
on travaille en équipe avec tous nos
clubs binois justement sur l'europe et
râlent sur les aides et si on peut on
définir au comité mais on peut aussi les
entraîner dans les clubs il ya près de
quarante mille licenciés 1 dans les
yvelines c'est bien ça oui nous sommes à
38,32 pour être précis et licenciés
cette année c'est une vrai sport comme
le football le golf l'équitation
alors on est expliqué on est le premier
sport individuel dans les yvelines
on a un taux de pénétration qui est qui
reste prom le meilleur en france qui
sont nés à 2 60% de taux de pénétration
dans les yvelines faut noter qu'on
progresse encore cette année 2 soit 0 75
% de licenciés ce qui est un bon
résultat puisque avec comme tout les
sports on a été en arrêt total pendant
deux mois et malgré tout on arrive à
terminer en hausse pour la deuxième
année consécutive
moi je rajouterai qu on a un réseau de
club de dirigeants et d'enseignants qui
sont très professionnels avec lesquels
on travaille et le fait qu'on ait de
bons résultats ça vient aussi de cette
qualité qui vient des clubs il y noir et
c'est vrai que le tennis historique dont
est un sport qui est vraiment très prisé
dans les yvelines oui alors on continue
à parler de roland garros je vous garde
avec nous et je vous propose un coup de
projecteur sur l'une des personnalités
de cette quinzaine parisienne du côté de
la porte d'auteuil n'est pas sur les
terrains mais au bord des terrains
je veux bien sûr parler de nelson
monfort le journaliste sportif de 67 ans
était dans les yvelines pour un tournoi
de golf amical à feucherolles c'est
l'autre interview express
[Applaudissements]
j'ai voulu devenir commentateur sportif
par par passion par par transmission si
le fait de transmettre cette passion
autour du sport qui accompagne ma vie
depuis le plus jeune âge mon meilleur
souvenir de commentateur sportif je
pense et l'arrivée du relais 4 x 100 m
nage libre aux jeux olympiques de
londres 2012 où les français ont réussi
à battre les américains non seulement
les américains mais également toutes les
autres équipes un dernier relais de
yannick agnel julich je m'en souviendrai
toute ma vie j'ai eu la raison pour
laquelle je m'en souviendrai c'est parce
que yannick ce jour damas a soufflé à
l'oreille tu es comme notre cinquième
relayeur ça ce sont des souvenirs qui ne
s'effaceront jamais eh bien tant que le
temps que le public me fait confiance
qui ce qui semble être le cas d'après
les sondages que je peux lire à droite
et à gauche je continuerai je pense que
tant que j'aurai cette cette passion
justement dont je parlais il ya quelques
instants
je continuerai cette année j'ai la
chance d'être sur le dispositif du tour
de france cycliste donc je pense que ça
devrait se poursuivre au cours des
prochaines années et puis naturellement
nous avons quand même c'est très très
belle perspective des jeux olympiques de
tokyo 2021 et puis ensuite de pareilles
2024 ce serait une si jolie manière de
tirer sa révérence peut-être qu est ce
que vous pensez de nelson monfort
magnifique magnifique qu'il est
passionné il fait passer les émotions et
le sport c'est vraiment des émotions
c'est ce qui fait bouger les gens donc
donnant un très grand commentateur
sportif et puis bah il est connu tout le
monde et sa crédibilité et la cua
surtout près les tennismans oui il adore
le tennis où ils adorent ça
merci à tous d'être passé sur ce plateau
on espère voir de nouvelles pépites
yvelinoise sur les terrains de tennis
dans le monde dans les prochaines années
merci à vous deux on prend maintenant la
direction de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines la structure a
accueilli ce week-end un concours
d'équitation trois étoiles avec de
nombreuses têtes d'affiché des images
d'astrid bergère l'événement était
attendu par les amateurs d'équitation
pour la deuxième année consécutive une
compétition internationale de concours
complet était organisée à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
l'événement s'est déroulé sur trois
jours du 2 au 4 octobre sur le plan
sportif le rendez-vous est passé cette
année de 2 à 3 étoiles
techniquement en fait c'est plus
difficile plus vous rajoutez d'étoilés
plus elle est techniquement difficile
donc ce sont des cavaliers de haut
niveau déjà bien aguerri avec des
chevaux beaucoup plus aguerrie aussi qui
courent sur ce genre de parcours
parmi les 400 sportifs présents des
étrangers ainsi que des stars de la
discipline le cavalier international
nicolas touzaint champion olympique en
2004 à athènes a participé à trois
épreuves mais je suis venu ici déjà
parce que il ya un programme qui était
intéressant pour moi et pour mes chevaux
c'est la première fois que je viens et
on est toujours ravi de faire un nouveau
concours parce que c'est vrai qu'on fait
les mêmes tous les ans après ça se
répète et là le fait de venir sur un
nouveau site qu'on connaît pas c'est
toujours assez assez sympa une nouvelle
édition est déjà prévue pour l'année
prochaine les organisateurs imagine déjà
un cross avec plus de difficultés en
football on jouait ce week-end le 4e
tour de la coupe de france et ce fut un
week-end compliqué pour nosy be noah
seulement deux clubs se sont qualifiés
pour le prochain tour
oui oui a réalisé l'exploit contre la
trinity l'atético de paris xiii en
gagnant aux tirs au but après avoir
réalisé un match nul de un partout dans
le temps réglementaire en garde
d'ailleurs cette magnifique photo de
joie à la fin du match
de son côté conflent a gagné 2 à 0 face
à gretz tournan dhoble les autres
rencontres à perdre 2 1 face à la
garenne-colombes chatou s'incline aux
tirs au but face à saint-maur exit
également les deux clubs de n2 versets
qui perdent 2 à 0 contre le plessis
robinson et poissy face à saint brice
s'est amené également pour les mureaux
et epône ont joué at également sur les
terrains de première division de
district le chili s'impose 3 1 face à
voisin vallée à 78 bûche loi se séparent
sur un score nul
sartrouville s'impose 3 1 face à bailly
noisy le match entre mu et bois d'arcy à
lui était un reporter on va maintenant
parler de l'aa régionale 3 maurepas est
l'un des clubs à suivre ce début de
saison les promus mort d'asia ont réussi
à remporter leurs deux premiers matchs
de la saison et ils sont en tête du
championnat avec six points pour nous en
parler nous recevons le capitaine mehdi
ewen et romain haas joueurs dans
l'équipe
bonsoir messieurs est-ce que vous vous
attendiez un début de saison pareille
deux victoires en deux matches c'est pas
maintenant c'est pas mal
ce concert seront s'y attendait je sais
pas maintenant c'est une bonne surprise
et on va essayer de continuer comme ça
de toute façon romain a confirmé oui si
on avait on nous avait dit ça avec la
préparation qui était un peu compliqué
avec des quatre co vide au mois d'août
du victoires en deux matches on l'aurait
on aurait signé et puis avec nos petits
moyens on fait nos petit bonhomme de
chemin et pour le moment ça se passe
plutôt bien
justement cette préparation estivale
elle a été un peu compliqué j'ai mecili
compliqué puisqu'on a dû arrêter une
semaine pour des quatre co vide donc
donc on ne te prépares être un petit peu
tronqué mais mais
on a tous bien bossé on a une équipe qui
est assez solidaires on a envie de on a
eu de se retrouver en a envie de
s'entraîner en vie de chat revenant
semble donc et donc ça paye ça se voit
tout de suite sur le terrain avec cette
victoire elle est ce beau match hier en
coupe de paris aussi ou face à nérac et
donc avec face à saint denis en 2002
agriculture but mais un bon match mais
c'est dans ma nature
alors vous êtes donc promu cette année
ce coup bénéficié un petit peu de votre
statut d'équipé surprise peut-être en ce
début de saison les autres équipes ne
vous connaissent pas forcément
peut-être peut-être c'est peut-être un
avantage pour nous à chaque début de
rencontre maintenant à ce que la
surprise ne se fera plus puisque les
équipes sont prévenues on a fait deux
victoires en deux matches ça va
commencer dimanche prochain à versailles
avec un beau derby je pense qu'on
rencontre une belle équipe je pense
réserve il n 2 donc ça va être très
difficile je pense alors vous avez une
attaque assez prolifique vous avez déjà
marqué sept buts
comment vous l'expliquez on a eu pas mal
de renforts
donc ça speak par part ça dans un
premier temps puis après on
je pense qu'on a le même socle ou des
kits que l'année dernière pour la grande
majorité on se connaît bien donc du coup
les automatismes fonctionne plutôt bien
et puis et puis on se donne un jour
qu'ils ont rejoint vite intégré et donc
ça fait aussi la différence des joueurs
qui s'intègrent assez rapidement et qui
rentre dans collectif donc ça va me
permettre d'être tout de suite prêt pour
les matchs et emma se montrer sur les
deux derniers résultats donc voilà alors
vous avez pas rentrer al'inverse
encaissé quatre buts depuis depuis la
saison qu'on vous l'expliquer c'est
peut-être la vitesse de jeu aussi qui
augmente en fonction de la division
c'est vrai que c'est plus dur que la
saison dernière
maintenant c'était vraiment sa
différence de niveau bah ça va plus vite
mais c'est pas non plus c'est pas
extraordinaire non plus après le temps
de s'adapter je pense qu'il ya encore
quelques réglages à faire
comme disait romain on a on a eu des
difficultés en début de saison avec des
quatre co vide mais aussi des blessures
et des absences personnel donc petit à
petit le groupe va se remettre au niveau
de l'année dernière et voire plus pour
pouvoir bien continuer cette saison vous
êtes premiers actuellement
est ce que ça sera l'objectif en fin de
saison d'être premier est mature et de
les gazer sur la plage dans le haut du
classement
c'est un peu utopique mais après mai
ça traîne de bois match et on va avoir
un petit peu comment comment ça va se
passer mais on a un groupe qui s'entend
bien on vit bien donc c'est on se refuse
rien et on espère un premier temps
l'objectif c'est vraiment de se
maintenir ça c'est sûr maintenant fera
le bilan à la mi-saison et voir s'il n'y
a pas moyen d'aller chercher comme je
l'aï dit la semaine dernière la montée
on refusera pas cette dernière question
très rapidement pronostic par rapport au
match de ce week-end ce sera ce dimanche
11 octobre vous affronter l'équipe 2 de
versailles un petit pronostic très
rapidement la victoire la victoire c'est
ce qu'on est ce un score 1-0 1-0 un but
d'alexis tissier merci à tous et de
dettes passées sur ce plateau le
prochain match à maurepas est donc
programmé ce dimanche 11 octobre sur le
teint de l'équipe 2 de versailles en
rugby et plus précisément en division
honneur c'était la reprise ce week-end
l'union rugby centre 78 la fusion du sky
rugby et montigny le bretonneux s'est
imposé in extremis 23 à 22 face à j agis
fois à l'extérieur ce côté chevreuse à
gagner sur le terrain de terre de france
de 39 à 22 au classement chevreuse et
lui verser 60 18 ans tous les deux à
égalité à la troisième place du
classement la prochaine journée aura
lieu ce dimanche
en basket en nationale 3 trap a
facilement battu le chili versailles sur
son terrain ce samedi soir dans le derby
yvelinois les trappistes n'ont pas fait
le détail ils ont emporté 94 à 58 cette
victoire permet à trappes d'occuper la
première place du classement avec trois
victoires en trois matches disputés
de son côté le chesnay versailles est 8e
sur 12 avec un match en moins
si les garçons ont perdu en nationale 2
féminine les filles du chesnay
versailles ont gagné l'ont emporté 53 46
sur leur terrain contre nantes reste
basket avec cette troisième victoire de
la saison en trois matches disputés les
yvelinoises occupe la troisième place du
championnat avec le même nombre de
points que le leader mondeville la
prochaine journée programmée ce samedi
sur le terrain d'angers
on passe maintenant notre page
découverte comme chaque semaine tv 60
vite vous propose de découvrir un sport
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur le
pilate une discipline pratiquée partout
dans les yvelines et notamment studio
céline à montigny le bretonneux ils sont
une soixantaine à prendre des cours en
fin de journée ou pendant leur pause du
midi pour se maintenir
en forme reportage de bixente mérion
santisteva inventé au début du 20e
siècle aux états unis par le gymnaste
allemand joseph pilates est ce le
pilates était à l'origine une méthode de
rééducation pour les danseurs
professionnels
la discipline a été élargie est
aujourd'hui accessible à tous le pilates
c'est une gymnastique de renforcement
des muscles profonds dont principalement
au niveau de la sangle abdominale et du
dos donc c'est un une gymnastique qui
permet de travailler son renforcement
profond
sa posture et de gagner en force et en
souplesse qu'il faut aussi avoir
conscience que le pilote c'est une
gymnastique de rééducation enfin nous on
peut vraiment aider tous les corps dans
tous les états possibles a continué de
se remuscler et à aller mieux
ils sont nombreux à y participer pour
pallier des problèmes de dos notamment
comme j'ai des problèmes de disques
intervertébraux dans le bas de la
colonne la musculation de la sangle
abdominale est très importante
et là j'ai vraiment une sangle qui me
maintient bien la colonne donc ça c'est
le premier point est le deuxième point
je gagne petit à petit en souplesse
moi j'ai choisi le pilote notamment
c'est parce que j'ai une courbe dans le
bas du dos donc en fait ça me permet de
bien combler et d'être bien maintenue en
fait au niveau de mon centre en bas mais
plus qu'une simple rééducation le pilote
peut être pratiqué à côté d'une autre
activité sportive pour se ressourcer
s'est notamment bien pour la danse fins
hamas oublie ça me détend c'est vraiment
top
j'ai cordellier là je suis bien en fait
je suis détendu et ça fait du bien
intense oui mais pour la bonne cause
mais attention le sport demande un
certain effort physique il y à
différents niveaux dont le cours avancés
proposant des exercices plus dynamiques
dans le pilates ya certains grands
principes peuvent le contrôler la
respiration mais aussi le rythme tant au
point de vue musculaire que cap
cardiaque puisque on a comme vous avez
pu le voir on a attrapé une bonne soleil
on a bien soufflé le studio c'est lines
propose des séances découvertes au tarif
de 10 euros pour tester l'activité
alliant sport et bien être
en rugby d'un championnat de fédérale 2
plaisir se déplacera sur le terrain d'or
c'est ce dimanche à 15 heures les
plaisirs oies qui affichent pour le
moment un bilan de deux défaites pour
une victoire après trois journées
tant à coeur de réussir une performance
à l'extérieur ils sont pour l'instant 7e
du championnat et on termine par du
football dans le championnat de
nationale 2 versailles recevra ce samedi
10 octobre au stade de porchefontaine
charte pour le compte de la 8e journée
et versailles et son temps en bleu ont
besoin de points ils sont actuellement
14e de n2 avec seulement deux victoires
depuis le début du championnat
chartres pointe seulement à un point des
joueurs de la cité royale la rencontre
s'annonce équilibrée
c'est la fin de ce sept huit sports à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]